[Music]
hey
there's a big friend reunions coming up
saying nobody cares but you know what
people do care about
remember matthew perry oh yeah he's
gotten very fat and he's fed all drunk
now
this was people have been hyping this
okay
people have been hyping this friends
reunion you know people that like
friends i hated friends i thought it was
a [ __ ] stupid show
but a lot of people have been hyping it
okay he went on
um this is a trailer okay fat all drunk
again
i love matthew perry he's one of my
favorites so
this this was him um when they were just
doing a little trailer for the hbo max
reunion show that they're doing okay
which it must have been really hard to
get a bunch of people that aren't
working anymore
uh well or having sex with david
arquette that's not fair to the cast of
friends most of them are
doing all right are they none of the men
are
none of the men are okay none of the men
aren't no i'll get
i will 100 percent conceal me
by the middle the male side of that show
did not outperform the ladies
um let's uh let's check this out
i stole the cookie jar that had the
clock on it
and i gave it to lisa kudrow
oh my god by the way no no go back let's
pause it right after he says and gave it
to lisa
cookie jar that had the clock on it and
i gave it to
lisa kudrow pause look it
look at david schwimmer look at how oh
god
but look at both of them because both of
them because joey i don't know his real
name
joey joey is just looking at him like
what the hell is wrong with you
hey schwimmer's disgusted he's just like
wow man
well you know what that means uh when
this when something like this does
happen
we have to play our favorite game
but now it's time for everyone's
favorite segment
where we ask you when to chat to try to
figure out
what drugs are they on something's gone
wrong
what drugs are they on
all right so let's see there everyone
this is a participation game
uh yes obviously booze right but i think
it's more than booze because he's he's
come out before saying he's been
addicted to hard drugs too
uh let's hear a little bit more the
cookie jar that had the
clock on it and i gave it to lisa kudrow
because she one point looked at it and
thought it was a real clock
um i'm going to say pills and booze
benzos you can't just say pills
benzodiazepines too generic behavior
benzos
benzo's not too generic right benzos and
booze i think benzos and booze would put
you
[ __ ] completely out i gotta say it's
either
i think he just has an alcohol problem
but i think he's
also probably prescribed either
antidepressants
or some kind of i think he's on some
some medication that's not necessarily
benzos
but like you know again antidepressant
type things you can't really mix those
with booze either because
uh or it's opiates but i don't he
doesn't i don't know not not everyone
has an opiate problem and he doesn't
seem too
so seriously doubt some people are
saying in the chat definitely booze
he has a secret stash of quaaludes
ketamine
he's this uh mr d ball money says we're
wrong that's actually just harlan
williams
that's very funny which one
kudrow cause she one point looked at it
and thought it was a real clock
and i gave it to her
[Music]
twitter has been very worried about him
matthew perry left fans worried after
the only
clip or they're just now we're gonna
make that okay so here's the thing we're
gonna get more tomorrow
because the show airs tonight this is
just a trade this was a trailer
to get people to watch people to watch
the show so vultures
in a couple days we're going to get and
remember
keep this in mind this is edited right
like the opi video we played uh
wednesday this is edited right so
the this is the best that cause you know
when you do a trailer you want to get
clips of everybody talking in the
trailer is everybody talking
this is the best clip they got of
matthew perry talking yeah i need that i
need that uh stuff that made the cutting
room floor that's what i want to see
yeah um i swear i got you know i
walked into the dressing room years ago
um jennifer hansen has some of the
nicest hits
dude you can't you can't do that man
um yeah man it's it's so this is them
they've been doing the whole media tour
trying to hype it
and um that's the best that they release
now could they have maybe released it on
purpose so more people tune in i guess
that's also
possible right but i don't know why you
would want to do that
um i'm trying to see if there's any more
i love the tweets when people go yeah
block me if you think it's something's
funny i'm like
no why do i have to do work yeah you
block me yeah you block me you [ __ ]
ass the other one is bothered
so i i found i found some of the i've
just found the interview that they did
this was them promoting it on people
let's see if there's anything else that
might be concerned
what's in the drawer behind you oh i'm
like in some
bedroom in florida just don't even look
please open the drawer
for us i can't stop thinking about
what's in the drawer behind
you page all right it's my daughter's
like clothes on vacation
fast and furious so and when the finale
you were mostly
it's a really it's going to be a lot of
them say what you want me to do
look at him look at him he looks fine
look at that that's like an old man
suffering from dementia not knowing
where he is
i think over the years we've we've all
struggled with different
did you see the blinks obstacles and
and times and have a call the only one
that the
close-knit group we don't here we go um
so that's been that's been nice while
being a really close-knit group
we don't see each other all six of us a
lot
he's [ __ ] hammered he's [ __ ] up man
he's definitely like i'll be honest with
you like i'll put it this way from the
perspective of
just the bar business if i was talking
to a customer
and he sounded like that i would go to
my bartender and i'd be like yeah you
can't
you got you got to subscribe stop
serving that guy and get him a water and
you know what i mean get him a red bull
on me or whatever but he can't drink any
more alcohol
yeah man i'm skipping through it and and
i'm just trying to see
they only gave him a couple it's like a
family it's like
i don't have sisters it's what i would
assume sisters are like like
siblings i would say yeah siblings very
supportive there's
very very very sexual very sexual
he's fine he's doing all right god
that's so bad chandler
yeah at the core yeah
at its core
he's just repeating the things they're
saying as score
it's like one of those like keep
yourself together keep yourself together
and like the guy who played joey just
looks like he put on some dead weight
and he looks like a normal guy his age
and then david schwimmer looks like one
of those weirdos probably just eats bean
sprouts
and has no fun but like for all the
great roles he's getting
and then you mean well he what do you
mean he was in uh what year was that if
you're going to say banner
brothers brothers what year was 2001.
okay that's right because it came out
right after 9 11.
yeah um yeah but he was in uh
who was he in
nothing okay that's what i thought